So, how did you come up with the idea of singing "After Tonight" in Japanese?
Well, it came to me from Ichisan.
It was the record company guy that I've worked with.
And he asked me about it a while ago. I was kinda skeptical about it and if I wanted to do it.
And then over time I realized that it would actually just be a great experience,...
...and nice for me to sing in Japanese 'cause I used to speak it when I was younger,...
...and that's a beautiful language.
It is?
It is, yeah.
But, what made you change your mind?
Just that, there's no need not to do it, you know?
And I used to take things a lot more seriously, and I'm kinda slowing down from that...
...because sometimes, I take the perspective of just the negative opinion or something like that...
...and now I'm certain to decide things more from a positive place,...
...and singing in Japanese is positive. It's great.
It should be a great experience.